hi I'm Maria you may know me at the
desert snob I love throwing party on
budget for my friend and family today
I'm going to show you my favorite tips
throwing dinner party on budget
today is a day before the party I'm
going to show you the tips how to make
your table beautiful instead of getting
paper towels or paper napkins I'd like
to go to thrift store and get cheap
napkins and decorate by myself here I
have knife and some paper napkin the
clothes I found at the thrift store and
potatoes and I have this nut
to protect my table and I have mastered
color paint so I have potato and I'm
gonna cut in half and grab a bowl from
your cupboard and I'm going to use
bottom of the ball and make a circle
line and this is kind of my guideline
and I'm going to cover around it and if
you don't have a crafty knife you can
just use
regular knife you use for cooking and
going to cut skin all right
I made a circle stamp I'm going to use
and dub and don't put too much
just the right amount and what I want to
do is I want to stamp in Center press
nice and firm so cute
and I'm going to keep doing this and you
want to put paint each time this is a
great way to add something personal to
your table
and you can obviously use any color you
want here you go this look like I bought
something from the store but instead I
made a front potato this is a great way
to make your table pop and making a
small gift for your guests another thing
I love to do a day before the party I'd
like to pull out my dish sheets so I can
figure out what kind of vibe my dinner
party is going to be and I love shopping
at the thrift store or antique shop flea
market they have so many Cody sheets so
all my plates are mismatched but that's
okay
those are all different sides and colors
but I think it's kind of fun and it has
very unique characters don't worry to
have full set of dinner wears just use
whatever you have and I promise you it's
just gonna work another budget friendly
way of decorating your table is using
candles I have a lot of cool candle
holders and I'm gonna just pull them out
and see how it works this is very
avant-guiled but I think it's really
cool
and this one I don't know what it is but
I thought it was very nice
and this one is a I know like mushroom
and I think it's kind of nice I think
the stable decoration can be a good
conversation starter as well I think it
is very cute very personal and again
this is a great way of throwing your
party on the budget alright so I have
all these sheets and Decor figured it
out and I'm so excited to cook big
dinner party for tomorrow
all right I'm getting ready for party
tonight flower can get a little
expensive so what I want to do is
foraging I'm lucky to live in Southern
California so I can always find some
fresh flowers or greens in my yard or my
walks so this is something I picked
today if you cannot forage where you
live you can always go to grocery store
and get cheap flowers like eucalyptus
would be great and it's elevate your
dinner table I'm boiling pasta and my
appetizer is ready so I'm going to
finish my table one of my favorite
things to use is butcher paper as a
tablecloth it is cheap and you can find
anywhere and it's super easy to clean up
I'm going to finish setting the table
and I'm going to write my guest name on
the paper and I'm gonna stick candles
another great way of saving money is
asking your friend to bring wine or some
dishes that way you can save time and
money I also like to keep my dinner
party vegetarian because it is great way
of not thinking about dietary
restriction I find meat and seafood is
expensive so keeping my dinner party
vegetarian it's a great way of saving
money
for today's appetizer I have beautiful
cruded plate with Dublin it's so
colorful and beautiful to make low
vegetable fancy it's all about texture
and color so you want to buy several
different kind of vegetables and cut
different weights so when you're cutting
carrots make sure to save green leafy
tops because I'm going to use it for
main dish any kind of dip whether
homemade or store-bought there is one
trick you can always do make it fancy
finish with extra virgin olive oil and
use some flaky salt freshly ground black
pepper and now my dip eats dinner party
ready so now I'm going to show you guys
my main dish do you remember I asked you
to keep the Carrot Top this pesto is
made with The Carrot Tops it's great way
of not wasting any parts of vegetable
but also you can substitute with basil
also pine nuts is the one of the most
expensive nuts so for my pesto I used
walnuts and I'm going to garnish with my
favorite toppings using garlic bread
crumb it's a great way of adding nice
texture to the pasta and it's so so good
so I'm adding a lot because I like this
so much and also I want to add some
fresh basil
but they kind of gives nice popping
color
and adds nice fresh flavor so my main
dish is ready so let me get other side
of the sheets I'm going to make big
green salad and I'm going to throw in
some squash it's roasted and I have some
oranges but if the squash is not in
season you can use any other root
vegetables like carrots or parsnips I
love having big leafy green salad for my
dinner party now I'm going to show you
guys what I'm going to make for this art
what is the desertion of dinner party
without the shawl stopping bizarre and I
love making Pavlova these are light and
early and a little bit tart and it's a
great dessert to finish fantastic dinner
party I'm going to make Pavlova using
egg white and I'm going to make card
with egg yolks so nothing goes to waste
this dessert is so beautiful and need a
hiding display so I'm going to use my
ball instead of using cake stand just
flip a bowl upside down and cake on top
I used orange for my side dish and I
used leftover orange for my purple lover
I also use lemon for my pesto and salad
so there is nothing to waste I want to
give some extra fanciness and I'm going
to use edible flour those are from my
garden so
um it's zero cost but
it's totally up to you you don't need to
use edible flour I think it gives a nice
cute pop in Pavlova
and takes everything up a notch again
this is totally optional so if you don't
have access to edible flour I think this
is as it is it's just beautiful
look at this beautiful dessert and my
dinner party prep it's done I have
everything laid out fresh crew today
delicious pasta and a beautiful dessert
my guest will be here soon so I'm going
to light my candles and I'm going to
turn on the music I hope you guys enjoy
my dinner party on budget tips if you
have any other tips comment below I'll
see you at the dinner party
oh my guests are here I'm gonna go get
them see you later